BACK TANGOOW TICE
CORRESPONDENT KATELYN POLANTZ ON
SOME MORS IS
INLER,
HOUSE SENIOR AECH IT TESTIFIED S
W N WITNESS TOST
COUNL.OKTH.
AT THE END OF THE ECTION, AN T O
WAD TOND JURY WHAT WE KNOW HE'TD
TOHE SEPARE
INABOUP'T ONJANUAR6tERS,
E CROWD THATVEEDITOL CHANTING
KNOW FROM PUBLIC REPORTINGM E ST
AFL THE OF 6 ARS  THE
UM  ABOIKE NCE,  TO
ELTI REST. TS SON THATWE HAVE I
FECOURT SYSTEMALLY
VING AT QUA CLIP A
REALLY FOCUSING AROUND DONAL
UM
WHAT HE WANG INSIDE THE E HOUSE.
OR
A ABOUT AS WELL.'RE ALSO HEARIT
'S FORMEOF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS, HE'SEED TO N
WHAT DOES THIS MFO?
>>L, THIS WAS AN ORDER FRO
AND IT BASICALLY SAIS  ARGUMFARE
HIS SEPARATE COB GEORGIA
OUT, WOULD
ED
THE REASON TIGIO IK MEADOW
AEEN THRESIDENTRERY, ES
S IN MS F 2020.E BECAME ASON  RH
YOU STEP TTR
TO LOOK AT GEORGTHNVESTINE
THERE ARE MANY INVESTIGATIONS
GOIN
SO WET FIRST, OTHER
INVESTIGATIONS MAYRSUE AND GET .
KA.
G.ONT" WITH ME IS EVAN NK YOU
PEREZ, CNNR JUSTICE ENT.
RYAN GOO, EDITOR IF JUST S
FORMER SPECIAL COUNSEL AT THE
IG, WHTORNEY FOR THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK
LET'S START  THE BIG NEW
EN ICOMES TO TD
, GUILTY ON
RGHOT  IT'S AN HISTORICA F
E Y TO HD E LEADER OMITI
THE UNITED STATEILOLENCE T
THETRAN
AND I THIN'S ALSR
ANT FOR WHAT COMES NEXT,
HELITIOU
THE PROUD BOYS AREO GOING TO
FO CHARGE.D R LAWYERS MUST HAVV
W FLIP ANE WITHNMENT, NOWEEIN
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CAN
FOR THADERD, IN THERR EVIDT COMN
OFAT POINT.
RYAN CALLSHOW STMENT?
SEDITIOUPIRACY?
RTMENT AS THEY WKETOWARDBRINGIN.
OUE RE
THT S MI SRWA TEATTORNEY HERE I
AND WHEN MERRICK GARLANDOVERNT,
AIN, THETH HEM REN MONTHS BEFD
AND  WHIRE THETR
CONGIOOCEEDING.ERE WAS METHE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AS TO WHE
MIGHT EVEN ALLOW E  GE THINGS V
STRENGTHENS THE HAN
TONE THAT TRUMPR TION OETCAS, N
FORMRE IMPEDING ANSFER O
CONSPIRACY TO
DO THAT IS PART OFE
ICRTMENT IUINGTHISTRENGTHEIR IOS
R DOLD?
, BIG
THIS IS A
E TOLD ABOUT T S DD
REDECTION OF THE IDEA
ORGANI ATOUS,ERIOUS, THATWAS NOL
IT WAS AY A ,
BRK OCRACY.
JURIES ARE NHEY CAN
ENSOMEONE HAS SAID LET ME  TO EY
T HAPPENS.U'REN
THE BAA E
RYAN, THE OTHER BIG NEWS THAT
IS THAT  T AIDE  ABOUT WITTELYNG
D MIERGHINTHERE.AS NOW TESTIFIE6
HE HAS FE ON  MTSPREPARATIOAND
INTEF ONALD TRUMP S
GIVING HIS SPEECH TO
N  CAPI Y S
O HE IS THE F PEONCAN GETO THE O
DOARY
CO SELEC
COMMITTEE, HE HAS A CONVERSATI
WIVER 25 MINEST THE SPEECH ANDC
OF THE UAGE OF MIKE.
ENTEPHEN MILLEYST
OUT
CONFRONTATION MORE OF IT COMESU
NUTES PLUSRYING TO GET
AT,  A
WE KTHHAT TO T
COMMITTEE.
LIKE OTHERS DIBU THEEXECE LLENAE
JUE FACT TESTIDE
SIGNIC TERMS OF THE TYPE
EE.
WEARD IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WHICH IS
THJAh COMMITTEE VERY
DI OF YOU AN
SITTING RO OF A FEDERA
GRAND JURY.
U'G SAID WHEN IT COMES
MEY EVERY
INVESTIGIOINLDTRUMP.
HE FOR
IORA.IS, KATE.
MA MEADOWS, IN MY VIEW
MOST IMPORTANT SINGLE WITNESS
W'SID
THHO-UP THS CALL
RAFFENSPERGER.
HARD WAY THAGR BPNA A CONGRESAL
REIO NEVER EVEN CHARGED WI
A GRANOUYORU
T D
GEORGIA ANDESDER OAJURYE A.Y
CRUCIAESTIONS TO ASK HIMHE'S TRL
AIDES ANOS HIM AROUND SOME Y MOE
HAVEN ORDERED TO TESTIFY HECOUN
HEADED?WHAT END?I WH, GRAHAM AWE
>> THE JUSTIENREALLY S BUT, AS .
N AT THEENLL THIS IS
DONALD TRUMP.